la gouverneure générale merci nous
accorder cet entretien bonjour mme
galipeau
on vous a beaucoup suivi comme
astronaute là vous êtes gouverneur
général depuis un peu plus d'un an
maintenant est-ce que la phase
d'adaptation est derrière vous a tout à
fait d'ailleurs il faut qu'elle passe
assez rapidement parce que ça roule
beaucoup dans cette fonction
c'est vraiment tout le côté
constitutionnel c'est vraiment la
mécanique et les affaires du
gouvernement tout passe par le bureau du
gouverneur général donc pour on doit
continuer la machine dès le moment où on
entre en fonction c'est ça rentre tout
de suite je suis très content d'annoncer
que suivant ma recommandation
sa majesté la reine a gracieusement
approuvé la nomination de madame julie
payette comme nouvelle gouverneur
général du canada
il n'y a pas de formation vraiment mais
est-ce que vous avez hésité avant
d'accepter ce poste quand on vous l'a
offert en fait très peu je vous dirais
j'ai reçu un appel au mois de juin et on
m'a je pensais que c'était pour autre
chose parce qu'on annonçait de nouveaux
astronautes
l'année dernière deux nouveaux
astronautes et je pense que c'est à ce
sujet là qu'on m'appelait et j'étais
complètement surprise qu'on me demande
de venir comme gouverneure générale mais
maintenant mon livre à moi lorsqu'on
lorsqu'on demande à quelqu'un de servir
son pays et qu'une seule réponse mais
j'écoute bas non ça se refuse pas quelle
est votre vision de ce poste-là
si vous parlez d'un de ce qu'on pourrait
laisser pour la postérité
ça je crois que l'histoire décide
qu'est-ce qu'on laisse pour la postérité
c'est pas les individus on est
tributaire ce qui se passe autour de
nous peut-être parce que les jackson
avait choisi le nord michaëlle jean
avait choisi les jeunes vous le thème
c'est la science on imagine la science
la technologie
j comme outil pour avoir d'effet prendre
de meilleures décisions
utilisé comme outil est aujourd'hui dans
cette société technologique c'est
important mais la diplomatie diplomatie
scientifique aussi la littératie
numérique
elle est de plus en plus importantes de
nos jours avec le bombardement
d'informations que nous recevons et le
pouvoir discerner le vrai du faux
demande littératie numérique importante
à voir c'est un sujet mais je vous
dirais que le sujet qui m'intéresse le
plus c'est la collaboration
j'ai été chanceux de faire une belle
carrière d'astronaute je suis allé deux
fois dans l'espace à bord de la station
spatiale internationale et j'ai
travaillé dans un milieu où des gens de
différentes nationalités de toutes
sortes de milieux de travail ensemble
tous les jours en harmonie et j'utilise
cet exemple comme une façon de décrire
qu'il est possible même lorsqu'on a des
opinions différentes même si on est
différent même si on a même désintérêt
pas tout à fait exactement ligne et il
est possible d'arriver un autre chose de
travers ensemble et d'accomplir de
grandes choses et c'est le thème
peut-être qu'ils qui a nous touche tous
et ça se répercute dans l'équipe aussi
radio-canada a pu confirmer auprès de
plusieurs sources que madame payet
s'adapterait mal à son rôle son
tempérament cela difficile et les
relations tendues avec son personnel
depuis son arrivée trois personnes qui
occupaient des postes de direction ont
quitté leurs fonctions
vous avez élu comme nous les critiques
qui a eu l'heur beaucoup de médias
anglophones surtout au sujet de votre
charge de travail justement vous dise va
à l'encontre des canadiens je fais tout
ça mais on vous reproche on vous a
reproché de d'en faire moins que votre
prédécesseur en termes d'engagement
public par exemple on le donnait les
chiffres mêmes
il en a fait je sais pas 200 et 296 j'en
avais fait 195 ans un tiers de moins
pourquoi personnellement je ne suis pas
certaine qu'ils ont pris leurs chiffres
parce que
on compare quoi avec quoi je ne suis pas
certaine qu'est-ce qu'ils comptent
exactement ce que je peux vous dire par
contre c'est que c'est ce que ce qui est
la réalité de toute ma vie de toute ma
carrière
nous travaillons très fort nous avons
des agendas souvent de 12 heures par
jour et on vient de terminer presque 20
jours sans congé parce que les choses
ont changé qu'ils avaient intérêt à un
mini votre crédibilité vous pensez on
s'est interrogé sur sur le changement
peut-être j'arrive je suis d'un milieu
scientifique ça ça peut peut-être
déstabilisé
j'arrive aussi très différente j'ai une
réalité différente de mes prédécesseurs
je suis mère célibataire j'ai un jeune
homme à la maison et lui me parle à du
haut de ses 15 ans de ce qui se passe
dans son monde et comment lui et ses
amis voilà on aimerait voir le monde
comment comment ils aimeraient qu'on
comprend qu'on résout les problèmes
qu'il n'y ait plus pauvreté qui qu'il
n'y ait plus de de méchanceté qu'il y
ait pas de violence
pourquoi ça aurait déstabilisé les gens
c'est une excellente question est aussi
et vous en êtes vous même est très
consciente jeune femme est souvent mais
la barre un auteur différent tout on
scrute personnellement j'encourage
d'être scruté les bilans les revues
c'est très important
basée sur des faits et sur la réalité
j'ai passé toute ma carrière à dans une
dans un domaine public où j'ai été
scrutés et est ce que une femme dans le
domaine public une femme scientifique
une femme dans des métiers non
traditionnels et souvent on lui demande
une perfection qui est presque
inatteignables possiblement et cette
perfection n'existe pas pour personne
est ce qu'il ya eu ou non un retard de
votre part pour la sanction royale pour
le fameux projet de loi sur le canal
malheureusement ça a été drôlement
rapporter ça aussi lorsque le
gouvernement a besoin d'une sanction
royale en général on l'a fait ici à
rideau hall
si on est à la citadelle on va la faire
la citadelle ce sont des sentiments
sanction royale écrite
sauf deux fois par année on a gardé la
tradition de la sphère dans la salle du
sénat qui est fermée maintenant pour les
dix prochaines années
d'ailleurs on a filmé le tout lors de la
dernière sanction et on doit arrimer
toutes les parties prenantes pour cette
activité
alors pour ce qui est de cellules et des
activités il ya toujours du bac une fois
de conduire en anglais mais vous n'êtes
pas senti bousculé par ce qu'on voulait
que vous signez une certaine date qui
était pas la taille qui était prévu nous
savons très bien qu'il ya deux fin de
session dans l'année et c'est à ce
moment où se donnent les sanction royale
en personne et c'est à la fin de la
session en juin la fondation convient
d'avoir ici en décembre des gouverneurs
généraux par tradition par haine ou
marraine dans votre cas des organismes
sans but lucratif
vous avez décidé de revoir cette liste
parfois il ya des organismes qui sont
parrainés depuis des décennies nous
avait voulu revoir cette liste pourquoi
est-ce que c'est fait et c'est encore
des dix organismes qui attendent en fait
tous les gouverneurs généraux france
cette activité et nous avons revu la
liste
effectivement et pour toutes les
organisations qui nous ont inscrits on a
terminé la revue on est en affaires avec
eux mais on a aussi tendu la main à
d'autres organisations qui elle date de
de dia s'est longtemps du temps où les
gouverneurs généraux venaient de
grande-bretagne venait pour un teint est
reportée après 4 sadate est un peu c'est
ça hein chaque chaque qu'organisation
chaque institution besoin d'être vu de
temps en temps
d'ailleurs c'est une bonne chose mais
revoir c'est peut-être une chose
suspendre les activités ou à laisser les
gens attendent comme ça pendant plus
d'un an peut-être que c'était un peu
exagéré pour certains
certainement nous aurions pu être avoir
plus de sécurité dans notre activité
dans notre communication avec certaines
organisations
aujourd'hui nous avons ce partenariat
bien en place et puis nous encourageons
aussi beaucoup les institutions de faire
aussi de 7,7 présidence d'honneur qui
l'ont sollicité et avec laquelle nous on
est très content de participer mais de
participer activement à ce que vous
reconnaissez qu'il ya eu des ajustements
avec votre personnel avec le bureau du
premier ministre pour que ça se fasse
mieux s qui a eu des problèmes de ce
côté là certainement qu'il ya eu les
ajustements comme dans toute nouvelle
organisation nouvelle équipe qui arrive
nouvelles façons de faire
nouvelle façon aussi d'approcher les
problèmes c'est normal c'est tout à fait
normal et c'est justement là n'ont pas
empêché la bonne continuation des
affaires et c'est pour ça que je suis
très fier on l'a vu récemment des
dépenses de vos prédécesseurs de
certains de vos prédécesseurs on a
appris que les gouvernants généraux
avaient droit à une à des frais de
voyage de bureaux avis qu'est ce qu'on
pensait de ce coût est ce qui s qui est
patent quand même de réformer un peu
l'institution de la secouer un peu pour
qu'on voit son utilité comment vous
voyez cette institution vous nous avons
donné un communiqué à ce sujet parce que
pour nous c'est très important en 2018
il est très important d'être transparent
de montrer aux canadiens
à quoi servent leurs impôts comment sont
utilisés les données publiques et ce en
toute circonstance et de revoir des
programmes qui date dans le cadre de ce
programme de soutien aux anciens
gouverneurs généraux de 1979
donc il est il va y avoir des revues qui
vont être faites et c'est quelque chose
que nous soutenons et que nous
encourageons qu'est ce qui va arriver
dans le futur
personnellement je ne suis pas certaine
que comme programme de cette envergure
soit encore nécessaire vers l'avenir
est ce qu'on doit refaire et réinventer
la roue par en arrière ça je suis moins
certaine et c'est ce qu'on veut regarder
parce que quand même plus de cent mille
dollars par année
c'est quand même beaucoup les choses ont
bien changé gouverneurs généraux
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que les gens
retiennent de votre mandat dans cinq ans
quand vous aurez fini qu'est ce que vous
voulez concrètement qu'on retienne de ce
que vous aurez fait comme gouverneur
général qu'est ce que je vais laisser en
arrière je crois que c'est quelque chose
qui est qui qui viendra de soi je
l'espère vient d'être authentique de
rester fidèle à moi-même d'insérer
l'esprit critique la la la force delà de
l'analyse que nous avons tous cette
force les sciences les technologies
comme outil pour prendre de bonnes
décisions de meilleures décisions pour
s'éclairer de mariée sciences et arts
parce qu'on entend souvent que les deux
n'ont rien à voir
et ça c'est un sujet qui m'a toujours
tenu à coeur mais surtout si on se
rappelle le ce mandat comme un mandat
collaboratif qui a ouvert qui a tendu la
main qui a qui ramenait ensemble toutes
sortes de faction à toutes sortes de
groupes une pensée très je l'appelle
horizontale pour essayer de rallier tous
se trouver le lien comme on fait les
connexions autant qu'on peut le
gouverneur général merci beaucoup
moi qui vous remercie